and you know here we are shireen a week
away from when
the washington post article regarding 15
former female employees of the
washington
football team had claimed they were
sexually harassed
and this past weekend operated as a hard
reset
we get into monday tuesday wednesday and
there's nothing i thought maybe
fedex would issue a statement to the
extent that fedex founder fred smith
is anxious to maybe nudge daniel snyder
out and when you consider that fedex
issued a statement over the name
would the sponsors do anything would
they say anything now that could all
still come
but i'm surprised that here we are a
week after
what was a pretty damning report not
nearly as damning as the online
speculation would have suggested but it
was still pretty damn bad
it's i don't want to say it's almost
like it never happened but
it sort of feels like it never happened
yeah we're not talking about it for sure
they did hire
another female in the organization in
football ops and and i do think they're
making some good moves but
yeah this thing's just disappeared very
quickly and and i know it's going to
bubble back up when
when the attorney starts getting
involved we start seeing the report of
what is found
but it is amazing that it how quickly
we've quit talking about this report
because it is damning
to the organization and and what we've
heard so far and there may
be even more to come out on this uh when
they start getting into
into it and looking within the
organization
but sharing let's play this forward a
little bit you've got an outside lawyer
who has no subpoena power who has no
ability to compel
cooperation from anyone who is not
currently
employed by the team you've got 15
former employees of the franchise
there's no guarantee
that one of them two of them all 15 of
them
will even cooperate they've got no
obligation
to cooperate the only obligation they
have under their severance agreements is
to keep their mouths shut pursuant to
their ndas i made the point yesterday
instead of ndas what these deals should
have in them whether it's a standard
severance agreement
that is signed when employment ends or a
specifically negotiated settlement
of complaints that were made internally
and maybe there's going to be litigation
and this is the way to avoid litigation
there should be a clause in those
agreements that says
that the person will cooperate with
any investigations that may unfold in
the future
conducted by the organization or by the
nfl
that there is an obligation as part of
that compensation received
in exchange for what typically is an nda
it's a it's an agreement that you will
disclose within the right
setting and the right circumstances
because
beth wilkinson the lawyer who's been
hired by daniel schneider may have a
hell of a time
getting anyone to talk and how ha see
that here's the other thing too and this
is why i'm skeptical of an investigation
being conducted by a lawyer who's being
paid by daniel schneider
there are ways that you can still get
the information you can be persistent
you can be extra charming you can be
creative you can stay outside of
someone's house you can just keep
keep trying and trying and trying if you
really
don't want to know what the person says
it's pretty easy
to not find out what the person is going
to say you make one phone call they
express some reluctance you say thank
you very much for your time you hang up
the phone and you cross them off the
list
so it's going to be interesting to see
how aggressive this investigation is
if and when former employees declined to
talk maybe bruce allen who's going to be
one of the key employees and
potentially one of the persons who this
former culture is blamed upon maybe he
refuses to talk i mean if you have key
former employees who say i'm not helping
you i'm not doing daniel snyder any
favors
you're not going to be able to conduct a
meaningful investigation so there is a
chance
that this just becomes one of those
things
that as time goes by and we focus on
other stories sharim
we just will think about it from time to
time like
like the the patriots bengals
taping of the sideline before the
penalties were announced on the same
night that the patriots signed cam
newton
which was the perfect time to announce
the signing of cam newton
but we just kind of forget about it
until we're reminded of it
until there's some reason for it to land
on the radar screen again it just kind
of goes away
i got a feeling that to a certain extent
this is just going to kind of go away
and uh it's going to take i think
diligence and persistence
on the part of the media to get updates
to get
you know we're never going to i we're
they're not going to make the final
report
available they're going to say this
deals with sensitive personnel matters
and it cannot be disclosed publicly i
guarantee you that's what they're going
to say so
i i i and and and i think they'll be
emboldened by the fact sharing that over
the course of the past week
it's all kind of already went away i i'm
i'm
i'm not real confident that that this is
ever going to come back and if it does
it's going to be more of a footnote than
a centerpiece
well fortunately there's people like you
mike to bang that drum and you'll
continue to do that and continue to
press for answers and
and so that's the fortunate thing and
that's why we need the media frankly
people say we don't need the media we do
need the media because things like this
will go away the dallas mavericks went
through this same thing
uh two two and a half years ago and
they've come out the other end they did
all the right things mark cuban did
absolutely all the right things they
went internally and looked he said he
cried for days
that and i don't know that dan snyder
has cried for days but
but mark cuban didn't like that in his
organization
uh that that his business ops had had
problems just like washington's going
through and he hired scent marshall
who was a very influential businesswoman
worked for a t
and he hired her to head the
organization and they cleaned up the
organization they gave 10 million
dollars to various women's groups and
and did a lot of the the right things
and i think now if you look at the
dallas mavericks they've come out the
other end of this no one's talking about
this
when they do talk about it it's like hey
they've done the right things within the
organization
it's a good organization to work for now
and uh
i know this washington has the right man
in charge
in in ron rivera to clean this
up if dan snyder continues to let him be
the voice and the face of the
organization
oh and he definitely is he's going to be
on cbs this morning to discuss the
situation with the washington football
team with gail king today so
you know it has crossed over into a
mainstream news story and the team is
treating it that way and maybe they are
in the process
of figuring out how to rebuild a
franchise that
has not been very good on the field and
has had these issues that
that need to be addressed need to be
fixed they're getting there with the
name
they apparently are going to get there
with the culture
and then fans ultimately hope that they
get there with the product
on the football field hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports